[Music]
now this weekend marks the 20th
anniversary of the 911 attacks and the
extraordinary debates which followed it
we had in christopher hitchens perhaps
one of the most articulate and unlikely
defenders of george w bush's war on
terror his brother and peter hitchens
joins me now he's written for the
magazine this week about the strange
intellectual convergence between the far
left of the 1960s and the
neoconservatives of 20 years ago now
peter you start your article by saying
that both you and your brother
christopher were very much against the
vietnam war
which one of you two changed your minds
intellectually
i think uh he did more than i did i i
think that
i i continue to view the vietnam war as
an amazing episode of stupidity in which
huge numbers of people
died by mistake uh a futile
enormous exercise of misdirected power
conducted by people who refused to
believe that sheer brute force could not
overcome the force of an idea and i
think that the the failure of the modern
western governments to learn or even
remember that lesson has been very
obvious in recent years particularly
over iraq but in lots of other places
too it continues to be obvious and
there's constant cruising for a bruising
which so many western powers
do particularly ourselves in the united
states that's endlessly looking for new
enemies whether it be libya
or in syria uh or in afghanistan rather
than accepting there are limits to power
i think this is this comes out of a
utopianism right you read this argument
consistently but but when you look back
20 years ago about the arguments for
basically about what what is the purpose
of western power if the west have got
these military then ought it to use the
military to put an end to what your
brother christopher referred to iraq as
a regime was which is a prison above
ground and a mass grave underneath he
was very much in favor of the kurds he
basically thought but the west could use
his liberal force to to nudge em
countries towards a more liberal outcome
that would be a huge mortal good now
that didn't work out that way but the
argument
what was pretty coherent wouldn't you
say at the time i mean you might say
well i didn't think practically the
military could do this but if you did
think practically the military could
depose a bad regime and usher in a
democracy then it would make sense if
you were a liberal to pursue liberal
interventionism
yes but i don't think anybody who'd been
alive and active during the the vietnam
period could conceivably think that
without closing a large part of their
their mind and their experience
and simply
ceasing to understand what we had
understood then the thing that happened
to the left was that many of them were
homeless because they they'd become
disenchanted with the soviet union by
1968
any kind of loyalty towards the soviet
union was pretty rare on the left but on
the other hand there was a very
considerable mistrust of and dislike of
the united states of its military power
of its intelligence agencies and its
influenced around the world anyway among
the left and the very curious thing is
how people who had that mistrust in the
1960s
were by the early parts of this century
actually siding with the united states
and viewing it as the new idealistic
power uh the new hope of utopia the news
the new place from which uh hope of
change for the better around the world
might come and that's the thing you use
the word nudge
here's the problem it wasn't a nudge was
it was an enormous uh and an extremely
ultra violent use of gigantic power uh
which
didn't achieve and in my view
predictably didn't achieve uh what it
was supposed to achieve but there was a
there was a transferred utopianism
which then caused a a complete loss of
proportion among people who ought to
have known better and it's it's
fascinating to to to look at the course
of my late brother's life in this and
there's a reason why i could speak with
some authority about this because i
argued with him in public and in private
about this and i i'd sensed that
something really extraordinary had
happened uh when he decided that he
he he was going to take the side of the
united states seek u.s citizenship and
become a partisan of war
after the uh after the great massacres
in manhattan and in 2001 september 11th
but he did and i it caused me to think a
great deal and this is this is my
conclusion i find that the left
has found a new a new source of of
utopian hope and that was it and that's
that's he was he was early in that
understanding
you see it is basically bringing the
utopianism of the of the early trotsky
idea of the affectability of society and
and seeing that through the prism of
liberal interventionism
well yes quite i mean because trotsky
remembers it was an inspiring figure to
to us on the left when we when we were
still trotskyist he was not associated
with stalin and therefore with the gulag
not associated with the nazi soviet pact
not associated with the invasions of
of central european countries to keep
them in line uh supposedly still a
representative of the of the ideal pure
cause which we supported along with rosa
luxenburg another untainted figure of
the left and
we were searching for something of that
kind my search for it ended in a
decision to believe that
no such uh no such force existed no such
hope
could be pursued that it would always
end in blood but other people still
wanted to have a utopian vision and this
provided it the idea that you could
actually
extirpate horrible regimes on the other
side of the world simply by the use of
force
was gripping and enthralling you asked
what these what what the power of of
great countries is for my viewers is
largely to defend themselves against
attack and to deter uh evil people from
attacking them rather than going out and
searching for causes to pursue
right but what about things like um the
kosovo sierra leone and tony blair's
other conflicts they were examples that
western intervention did till things for
the better surely
kosovo was a fascinating practice run
which i found instinctively repellent
and thought wrong and i remember
discovering for the first time what it
was like to be uh unpopular with with
readers who had previously
been in accord with me uh because i just
thought that there was something really
quite seriously wrong about intervening
in in other countries to to tell them
how to run themselves i still do
but it was it was very minor by
comparison with the much bigger uh
intervention of iraq but i do think i
now do think
uh it was an unintentional dress
rehearsal for it and it came from the
same drive it came from the same
blairite belief
that you could remake the world
with the use of military force now by
the time that your brother and passed
away had he changed his mind in this did
you keep talking to him about it because
it was fairly clear
that iraq had not gone the way people
wanted it to if you look at the
humiliation in basra the triumph of the
mahdi army the insurgents it was harder
to argue even within three or four years
of the invasion that iraq was going in
that
in that direction so was there any
indication
did the two of you get closer in your
analysis of what i think if you if you
went through everything everything you
said and wrote i think he he made some
admissions of
misjudgment i think in general he still
thought the enterprise had been a good
one i mean he moved on very much then to
concentrating far more on attacking god
than attacking saddam hussein but i
don't think that he ever really
concluded that his support for the war
had in itself been a mistake
right and you say in your article that
you think it's the the far left dislike
of organized religion um that also
transported itself into an attack in
islam and it certainly is islamic rule
islamists jihadis
and it was
i guess i'm trying to work out if you're
saying that you believe that parts of
the neoconservative movement part of the
war and terror was driven simply by a
dislike or suspicion of religion and
theocratic regimes
well i think that there's obviously a
very great dislike of
militant islam or islamism or however
you want to
to
describe it to avoid confusing it with
islam as such uh in large parts of
western society and it has many
different origins
but i think a lot of american
neoconservatives are very hostile to
islamism and i think the fascinating
thing for for persons on the left
who had previously been
separated by a great gulf from
neoconservatives and conservatives of
any kind found a point of alliance in
that they could they could
full-throatedly attack
uh this particular form of religion uh a
atheistic religion which they disliked
and still find themselves on the same
side as conservatives so it was a very
useful bridge i think of which certain
people could walk so they could embrace
people who they would not previously
have had much to do with i don't think
that my late brother would ever have
thought much before september the 11th
that he'd had spent much time with with
people such as paul wolfowitz
but he ended up doing that and i think
the the the fury against militant islam
made that rather unlikely embrace easier
so i think it was important from that
point of view but i think you'll find
that that
left-wing people had always disliked
islam but they they also dislike
christianity if they emphasize the
dislike of islam they could make and
keep new allies
and you also argue in your piece that
they
not that they liked violence but they
were more at peace with the notion of
mass violence to achieve aims hence
communism and and you said they basic in
a way the violent aspect of the war and
terrorism was part of the attraction for
this certain cohort of idealists well
utopianism is in fact by its nature
violent it it foresees the overthrow of
of the things which it which it hates
and wishes to sweep from the surface of
the earth i think still
a quick reading of the original 1848
communist manifesto shows a considerable
desire to overthrow the existing order
and that has to involve
an acceptance
of violence of course the people
involved did not personally wish to go
around killing and bombing other people
but an acceptance a willingness to to
support and endorse
certain types of violence in this case
state violence uh visited on foreign
countries by the governments of the
united states and britain
and where do you think the energy is now
then if the energy was in believing that
the trotsky knight project in the 60s
moved on to the neoconservative movement
in the last 20 years where does it stand
now after the debacle in afghanistan has
it moved on to other causes or just
dissipated i think i think a lot of the
a lot of the debates about the
withdrawal from afghanistan has been
fascinating in its apparent confusion a
lot of people who you might have thought
would be on the side of president biden
attacking him for pulling out of
afghanistan a kind of yearning for a
continued intervention or indeed
a new intervention a lot of a lot of
fuss being made at the moment about
events in the panchayat valley as if
there might be a resistance in
afghanistan which perhaps we might
support in future i think they've
abandoned this idea that we can
intervene violently
for
for the good of the world in fact
as far as i can tell
that idea still has some mileage in it
in syria where the the west and its its
gulf allies still haven't completely
given up their attempts to overthrow the
assad regime and i have to say i i live
in considerable fear that we will we
will find some point
which we will pick a quarrel with iran
which might well lead to violence and
even with russia so no i don't think
it's gone away at all i think it's
seeking a new direction but i think the
the the direction supposedly provided by
september the 11th turned out to be the
wrong one and i'd
say i think it's fascinating to see that
uh that president biden himself is now
talking about opening up various closed
documents but what always struck me
about september 11 was how many of the
hijackers had come from saudi arabia
and what about your own branded politics
because you say now that basically
countries ought not to interfere with
other countries but doesn't this fairly
quickly become isolationism and
when great when great powers choose not
to help police the rest of the world
then you'd certainly turn the blind eye
to troublemakers and as romsfeld said
weakness can be more provocative than
strength so at the moment with america
turning in on itself i guess you are
advocating presumably that britain keeps
to a minimum all sorts of foreign policy
adventures doesn't that risk
destabilizing the country and
encouraging the forces the liberal
forces which surely somebody if you're a
classic liberal if you're conservative
you basically believe in freedom and
democracy surely ought to believe that
our country has got a role to play in
encouraging that democracy in other
places and in using and applying our
force in areas where it can help
well i'd like all good things including
charity uh
democracy liberty and
such things begin at home i think we
have very grave tasks at home in
establishing uh a better form of
governance than we have now and
re-establishing the adversarial
parliament which we used to have which
we've lost and rediscovering the rule of
law
rebuilding such things as habeas corpus
and the presumption of innocence which
we've chucked aside if you want to go
around the world saying certain
countries are not very well run i think
it's a very good idea to make sure your
own country is well run
first and at the moment we have many
domestic concerns i also either simply
are not
uh and should
stop behaving as if we were a great
power and we have still we're planning
to renew the trident nuclear weapons
system which is a is a cold war
superpower weapon the cold war is over
we're not a superpower i don't object to
us having some sort of nuclear defense
because we've spent so much on
developing it but the ridiculous size
and scale of it is crippling us and does
no good we we shouldn't overestimate our
power it's all very well saying yes we
should intervene in all kinds of
countries there's several things wrong
with it in if you if you then
selectively don't intervene in various
tyrannies which it happens not to suit
you to intervene it doesn't really seem
to be very principled to me to intervene
intervene intervene only against weak
countries but it but even if that was so
the history of these interventions has
been so catastrophic uh i think i said
one of the ones which is very little
discussed naughty more so is david
cameron's ridiculous intervention in
libya which has caused nothing but death
and destruction and
misery and many other things besides
these things are so bad that we should
think very even if you believe in them
you should think far more seriously
about about undertaking than we have
done so far i i personally think it's
easier to start from from a position
that it's better not to do them at all
and have to be argued very very hard
into doing it my own my own my own
strong predisposition is against it i
can see that other people could
sometimes say well what about sierra
leone but i think sierra leone is a very
very rare example of this kind of thing
and certainly couldn't be elevated into
a principle and when you set it beside
the damage done by libya it doesn't
really justify this policy of reaching
immediately for the jet fighter and the
missile uh rather than thinking of some
other way of improving the world but
start with yourself if you've got a
country like ours with serious and
growing knife crime the most disastrous
education system in the modern world
and as i say a a non-functioning
democracy uh where many of our most
precious possessions in liberty are
under great threat let's sort that out
first before we go and go telling the
syrians how to run their affairs right
but are you saying that iraq right now
would be better if saddam hussein was
still in power that libya right now
would be better if gaddafi had been
allowed to march on benghazi put his the
rebels to the sword and continuing i
mean would the world have been better do
you think well better for whom i i'd
you'd have to ask for the libyans for
the iraqis
about the message that was sent valene
putin knew right now is we'll be testing
limits of his power in lithuania in
georgia to see if the west is willing to
defend his values if we're not in the
way that you suggest you can certainly
see how the bad guys would get involved
and history teaches us what happens when
those bad guys do get emboldened and in
an expansionary mood
when you're writing a lot of arguments
here how long have we got but
i think that our attitude towards
towards russia it's frankly ridiculous
and unfactual this is a country which is
withdrawn from hundreds of thousands of
square miles of territory with without a
fight and we treat it as an aggressor in
a ridiculous fashion but as i said
that's another longer argument
are people better off
or worse off i when i have to say when i
visited baghdad not long after the
invasion
people were in many material ways uh
worse off and there were other things
which which we
we claim to value uh such as the
treatment of women which had gone
substantially backwards it's very hard
some uh to work out but i don't think i
think you'd be pretty hard put to find
anybody in libya uh who thought that the
current fiery bloodstained cauldron
which that country has been reduced to
is
is uh is an improvement on what went
before but
what you mustn't do is try to to confuse
my saying that we've made bad mistakes
and done bad things uh with my saying oh
yes i love gaddafi i'm an apologist for
saddam hussein i i don't think it should
the argument should be crammed into that
extremely narrow and
crude oversimplification i have no more
liking for saddam hussein than you do or
anybody else does that's not the point
the point is did we do good or did we do
harm
both to the people there and to
ourselves i think it's pretty clear that
we did harm
[Music]
you